bonsoir un avion d'air france a été
détourné en début d'après-midi il
assurait une liaison entre vienne et
paris
quatre ou cinq pirates de l'air sans
doute des libanais ont obligé l'avion à
se poser à genève après avoir obtenu le
plein de carburant
libéré 37 passagers les pirates l'ont
obligé à repartir
ils volent en ce moment même vers
athènes hervé brusini était cet après
midi à l'aéroport de genève cointrin
depuis 15h05 heure de son atterrissage
cet appareil est placé à l'écart sur les
beats l'aéroport de genève et aux
personnes qui sont à l'intérieur et qui
arrive de vienne en autriche vivre ce
qu'on appelle un détournement d'avion
quatre terroristes qui s'expriment qu'en
arabe y est en effet de comparer de
l'appareil et mandat la tour de contrôle
pour invita immédiatement l'avion
armés de mitraillettes et de nombreuses
grenades ils veulent tout de suite
repartir vers une destination qui n'a
rien à voir avec celle prévue l'aéroport
charles de gaulle à paris ils veulent se
rendre à sofia le gouvernement suisse se
réunit alors en état major de christie
consul général de france est là avec à
ses côtés un émissaire du gaston
defferre ya 16h04 devant le
ravitaillement qui tarde des terroristes
menacent de faire sauter l'avion à la
même heure et c'est une pure coïncidence
au sein même de l'aéroport qui relie à
une alerte à la bombe
immédiatement résolu par l'enlèvement
d'un paquet suspect à 16h17 c'est le
décollage dans autorisation l'aéroport
destination athènes à peine pourtant
comme sophie a refusé pour l'instant de
recevoir l'avion quand cette personne
non plus être libérés deux heures après
l'atterrissage
11h13 femmes et 13 enfants des femmes et
des enfants qui attendent avec angoisse
la suite des événements que l'on vive de
leur famille ont presque dans la vie
ce détournement d'avion coïncide avec
l'ouverture de la conférence
internationale de la palestine qui
s'ouvrira lundi à genève des mesures de
sécurité exceptionnelles ont été prises
on le voit aux abords des records et sur
l'aéroport ce déploiement de force n'a
pu empêcher détournement ni même
contraindre les pirates tout cela doit
bien inquiéter les autorités suisses
puissent qu'au moins 95 pays sur les 157
membres des nations unies ont déjà fait
savoir qu'ils participeraient à cette
conférence
et pourtant les suisses ont pris au
sérieux la sécurité des participants la
preuve ce panneau en plusieurs langues
et la mine déterminé de ce soldat si
nous obtenons de nouvelles informations
bien sûr nous vous tiendrons au courant
de ce détournement tout au long de ce
genre